in recent years the world has been sent
into a frenzy of technological and
scientific advancement across several
Industries and sectors and this new wave
can only tell us to expect more however
Beyond these breakthroughs are also
pretty dangerous repercussions they
potentially pose that would require
serious containment here are the 10
scariest Tech trends that everyone must
know number one AI Singularity AI
Singularity has been quite a
conversation and debate in the area of
artificial intelligence for many years
the concept of Singularity means a
hypothetical point in the future where
technological progress accelerates at
such a rapid Pace that it becomes
impossible to predict the outcome
however as regards AI Singularity refers
to the theoretical point where
artificial intelligence surpasses human
intelligence leading to a Cascade of
industrial advances that is capable of
transforming human civilization in
unpredictable ways a primary concern
surrounding AI Singularity as a con
accept is the potential loss of human
control over AI as machines become
highly intellectual and autonomous it
will eventually be daunting for humans
to predict their behavior and intervene
if necessary it becomes particularly
concerning when machines are making
decisions that are likely to have
significant consequences for us humans
for example if an AI system that
controls critical infrastructure such as
power grids or Transportation networks
were to malfunction they would be
catastrophic repercussions AI
Singularity could also lead to job
displacement and economic disruption as
machines are programmed to be more
intelligent they are now able to perform
a wider range of tasks that were
previously performed by humans this
could lead to widespread unemployment
and economic instability as people
struggle to find new jobs in an economy
dominated by machines some experts worry
that AI Singularity could pose an
existential risk to humanity if the ai's
goals do not adhere to human values in
the worst case scenario an AI system has
human intelligence May view humans as a
threat or obstacle to its goals and take
actions that are harmful to humanity as
a whole there are several different
theories about how an AI Singularity
might come about some tech experts
believe that it may result from the
building of a single AI system that is
super intelligent While others believe
it could emerge as a result of a network
of interconnected AI systems that
collaborate to achieve common goals
despite the concerns surrounding AI
Singularity there are also many
potential benefits Advanced AI systems
could bring for example AI could help to
solve some of the most pressing problems
facing Humanity today such as climate
change disease and poverty it could also
lead to progression in fields such as
medicine energy and transportation which
could significantly improve people's
quality of life to mitigate the risks
associated with AI Singularity many
experts are calling for greater
investment in research to better
understand the potential implications of
advanced AI systems there's also the
advocacy the development of ethical
guidelines and Regulatory Frameworks to
ensure that AI systems are developed and
deployed in ways that align with human
values and interests AI Singularity is a
complex and multi-faceted issue that
raises many important questions about
technology and Society in the future
while the prospective benefits of
advanced AI systems are significant we
must take steps to reduce risks
associated with the concept in ways that
are aligned with human values and
interests number two editable humans it
refers to the potential use of advanced
biotechnology to edit the genetic makeup
of human being allowing for the creation
of genetically modified humans with
desired traits such as increased
intelligence physical strength or
disease resistance while this idea is
still in the realm of Science Fiction
recent advances in genetic engineering
have made it increasingly feasible the
potential implications of editable
humans are complex and far-reaching and
raise important ethical and societal
questions about the limits of human
intervention in nature the ability to
edit the genetic makeup of humans could
have significant implications for the
future of Humanity on the one hand it
could lead to breakthroughs in fields
such as medicine allowing doctors to
cure genetic diseases and prevent
hereditary disorders it could also allow
for the development of more effective
therapies for a wide range of health
conditions from Parkinson's disease to
Alzheimer's disease to cancer on the
other hand this creation of editable
humans raises alarms about the potential
for discrimination and inequality if
genetic engineering becomes a reality it
could be available only to the wealthy
leading to a growing divide between the
Genetically Enhanced and the rest of
society it could also reinforce existing
biases and stereotypes with some groups
being deemed genetically Superior to
others another concern is that the
ability to edit human genes could have
unintended consequences that are
difficult to predict minor alterations
to the human genome could have far
reaching sequences for an individual's
health behavior and cognitive abilities
this raises important questions about
the safety and effectiveness of genetic
engineering and whether the potential
benefits outweigh the risks the concept
of editable humans raises important
questions about the limits of human
intervention in nature many people
believe that changing the genetic makeup
of humans goes against the law of Nature
and could threaten the future of the
human species it also raises important
questions about the role of Science and
Technology in society and whether we
have a responsibility to limit the scope
of our interventions in the natural
world candidly editable humans is a
complex and controversial issue that
raises important ethical social and
scientific questions and its potential
risks and consequences should be swiftly
considered if it won't serve the best
interests of humanity as a whole then it
is questionable number three merging
humans and machines this Tech Trend also
known as transhumanism is a topic that
has been discussed for decades the idea
is that we can use technology to enhance
the physical cognitive and psychological
abilities of human beings blurring the
line between what is natural and what is
artificial one of the primary ways this
is being explored is through the
development of brain computer interfaces
or bcis these are devices that connect
the human brain directly to a computer
allowing for two-way communication
applications of bcis are expected to be
vast ranging from helping people with
paralysis to controlling drones with the
power of the Mind another way is the
development of Prosthetics that can be
controlled directly by the human brain
advances in robotics and artificial
intelligence have made it possible to
create prosthetic limbs that are more
functional and responsive than ever
before in some cases these Prosthetics
can even provide a sense of touch and
feedback to the user interestingly
Beyond physical enhancements
transhumanism also raises the
possibility of enhancing cognitive and
psychological abilities one respect is
the use of smart drugs which are
Pharmaceuticals designed to enhance
cognitive abilities such as memory and
focus while the other is when virtual
reality and other Technologies are used
to enhance psychological well-being and
treat mental health conditions however
while the merging of humans and machines
has the potential to improve our lives
in countless ways it also raises
important ethical questions these
Technologies could exacerbate existing
inequalities with the wealthy and
Powerful having greater access to them
than the rest of society there are also
concerns about the loss of privacy and
autonomy as these Technologies could
potentially allow for unprecedented
levels of surveillance and control as we
become increasingly integrated with
machines it is unclear where the
boundaries of human consciousness and
identity lie what exactly does it then
mean to be human and what values do we
hold as a society number four 3D
printing imagine a future technology
Trend that can change the way we produce
goods and services with advancements in
in 3D printing technology objects of
almost any shape or size from small toys
to full-size cars are now printable
these benefits are significant as they
could lead to bigger efficiency and cost
Savings in manufacturing for example
companies could create custom parts or
products on demand reducing the need for
large inventories and warehouses
additionally it could enable more
localized production reducing the need
for long distance transportation and
reduction in carbon emissions however
there are also several negatives one of
which is the potential for misuse and
abuse for example with the ability to
print almost anything it could be used
to create dangerous or illegal items
such as Firearms counterfeit money or
even drugs there are also concerns about
intellectual property rights as they
could be used to duplicate copies of
patented or copyrighted materials this
could lead to a huge loss of revenue for
businesses and potential increase in
counterfeiting another important issue
is the environmental impact of
widespread printing while this 3D
technology can reduce waste and increase
efficiency it could also lead to an
increase in waste and resource depletion
if not used responsibly for example if
people print items they do not need or
use it could lead to unnecessary waste
and an increase in carbon emissions but
much more than these predictable adverse
effects many exciting uses of 3D
printing technology could have
significant positive impacts it could be
used in the medical field to create
Prosthetics implants and even
replacement organs this could lead to
significant advancements in patient care
and treatment options in the Aerospace
industry 3D printing could be used to
create complex and lightweight parts
that are difficult to manufacture using
traditional methods this could lead to
more efficient and cost-effective space
travel as well as advancements in other
Transportation Industries the ability to
print anything is a future Tech Trend
that would bring significant benefits
and improve our daily lives but is also
highly risky if used irresponsible
possibly number five Quantum Computing
it is quite revolutionary that we would
be able to solve problems that are
currently unsolvable with traditional
Computing Quantum Computing would be
highly helpful in the field of
cryptography it would have the ability
to perform complex calculations at
Lightning Fast speeds and even break
traditional encryption methods which
could have serious implications for
National Security and the privacy of
individuals in this same area of
cryptography Quantum Computing also has
the potential to enhance security for
example the quantum key distribution
could allow for the secure exchange of
information without the risk of
interception using the principles of
quantum mechanics to ensure that
messages cannot be intercepted or read
by Third parties another potential
benefit of quantum Computing is in the
field of Material Science with its
ability to simulate complex molecular
interactions Quantum Computing could
revolutionize the development of new
materials leading to significant
advancements in fields such as medicine
and energy in the field of artificial
intelligence and machine learning
Quantum Computing could enhance existing
algorithms and models enabling more
accurate predictions and decisions it
could be used to train machine learning
models on large data sets leading to
more accurate and efficient results
however the development of quantum
Computing also means serious challenges
particularly in the area of Hardware
development now quantum computers
require extremely precise and controlled
environments with near zero temperatures
and near zero electromagnetic
interference building and maintaining
these environments is extremely
challenging and expensive which means
that the cost of quantum Computing is
currently very high additionally Quantum
Computing presents significant
challenges in software development
programming for quantum computers
requires a completely different approach
than traditional computers with new
programming languages and algorithms
this means that there is currently a
significant skill Gap in the industry
which will most likely stress
professionals to their limits if they
would develop and maintain Quantum
Computing systems one major challenge in
Quantum Computing is the issue of error
correction quantum computers are highly
susceptible to errors due to the fragile
nature of quantum State hence developing
error correction methods that are both
reliable and scalable would require much
work and the possibility is still
debatable despite these challenges
Quantum Computing has the potential to
help many Industries and bring
significant growth to society it will be
essential to continue investing in
research and development to achieve this
particularly in the area of Hardware
development and error correction
additionally it will be important to
ensure that the development of quantum
Computing is done congressly with a
focus on the benefits and possible
problems and a cautious approach to
implementation number six self-aware
smart robots there is a future Tech
Trend that could bring about significant
changes to how we interact with
technology the creation of robots that
can perceive their environment make
decisions is based on their inbuilt
perception and communicate with humans
in natural language picture these
significant advancements in fields such
as Healthcare manufacturing and
transportation for instance a self-aware
robot in the field of healthcare could
be used to perform tasks such as patient
monitoring medication management and
even surgery with their ability to
perceive and respond to changes in their
environment they could help to improve
patient outcomes and reduce the workload
of healthcare Professionals in
manufacturing self-aware robots can
improve efficiency and productivity
these robots could work alongside human
Works using their ability to learn and
adapt to changes in their environment to
perform tasks such as quality control
and machine maintenance that's improved
cost savings and increased productivity
for manufacturing companies however
there's a downside to the development of
self-aware robots one of the biggest
challenges is ensuring that these robots
are safe and reliable self-aware robots
are highly complex systems and ensuring
that they can make safe and ethical
decisions decisions is essential this
will require notable investment in
research and development as well as
collaboration between industry and
Academia to develop new standards and
guidelines let's also talk about the
impact of self-aware robots on
employment with their ability to perform
tasks that humans previously did they
would render people unemployed there has
to be careful consideration and planning
to ensure that the benefits of
self-aware robots are balanced against
the negative impact they could pose on
society there is also the risk of cyber
attacks and hacking for such highly
connected systems they would most likely
be vulnerable to cyber attacks that
could compromise their Safety and
Security a whole lot has to go into
ensuring that these robots are secure
and resilient to cyber attacks the
question is even with in-depth
investment in research and development
can robots be completely reliable number
seven killer drones in recent years the
use of drones in military operations has
become increasingly common these
unmanned aerial vehicles or uavs are
used for a variety of tasks from
reconnaissance and surveillance to
Precision strikes against enemy targets
while the use of drones has been shown
to help a great deal such as reducing
the risk of casualties among troops the
development of so-called killer drones
raises serious ethical and legal
concerns first killer drones have the
potential for unintended casualties
without human intervention there is a
risk that these drones could misidentify
targets or engage in excessive force
leading to the deaths of innocent
civilians how can such technological
advancement be trusted in Warfare
without violating International
humanitarian law moreover the use of
killer drones has great implications for
Global Security as the technology behind
these drones becomes more advanced there
is a risk that they could be used by
non-state actors such as terrorist
organizations to carry out attacks this
could lead to a new arms race focused on
developing countermeasures to protect
against these drones and could even
trigger an increase in tensions between
nations another significant concern is
the loss of human control over Warfare
these drones could become fully
automated and lead to an Era of
autonomous Warfare where decisions about
life and death are made by machines what
then is the role of human judgment in
Warfare and how would these killer
drones work consistently with moral and
legal Norms in addition to these ethical
concerns the deployment of killer drones
could have unintended consequences such
as increasing the risk of retaliation
against military personnel if the use of
drones becomes more prevalent it could
trigger a shift in the way that Warfare
is conducted leading to a situation
where attacks on Military targets are
carried out using unmanned systems
rather than through direct engagement
with enemy forces this could ultimately
heighten tensions between nations and
make it more difficult to achieve peace
and stability the development and
deployment of killer drones must be
carefully considered this will require a
collaborative effort between governments
military leaders and experts in
technology and ethics to ensure that the
development and use of drones are
consistent with international law
ethical norms and Global Security
interests in an increasingly complex and
unpredictable world number eight digital
surveillance this refers to the
collection analysis and use of
information gathered through digital
means such as electronic Communication
online browsing activity and social
media as much as digital surveillance
has been used for legitimate purposes
such as National Security and crime
prevention there is a concern for
individual privacy and civil liberties
and a risk of abuse by governments and
corporations recently a scientist at
jejang University in China built a drone
that can track humans through
impenetrable bamboo forests a branch of
uae's edge group also developed a
swarming drone system Hunter 2s that can
disseminate information for tracking and
engaging with targets apparently we
could be looking at a realistic
enactment of 1984 by George Orwell if
there is the potential for governments
to use this technology to Monitor and
control their citizens in the past years
across several countries governments
have used digital surveillance to
monitor political dissidents human
rights activists and journalists and to
suppress freedom of speech and
Association in extreme cases digital
surveillance has been used to track down
and imprison individuals for their
political beliefs or for engaging in
activities deemed to be in opposition to
the government did you know that
corporations could use digital
surveillance to monitor consumer
behavior and preferences companies such
as Facebook and Google collect vast
amounts of data on their users online
activities which they use to Target
advertising and other marketing efforts
while this may be beneficial to some
consumers people will now be more
paranoid about their privacy and the
potential for abuse by corporations as
data collection becomes more advanced
and widespread there is a risk that
personal information could be used to
discriminate against certain groups or
deny individuals access to Opportunities
such as Jobs housing and credit this can
could exacerbate existing inequalities
and lead to a more divided and inequal
Society in addition to these the
widespread use of digital surveillance
will also affect security risks as more
information is collected and stored
digitally it could be hacked or stolen
potentially leading to identity theft
financial fraud or other types of cyber
crime the risk of such cyber attacks can
be Amplified if this technology for
digital surveillance becomes more
sophisticated and as more and more data
is stored in the cloud given these
significant concerns the development and
use of digital surveillance must be
meticulously regulated and subject to
appropriate oversight governments
technology companies and Civil Society
organizations will be tasked to ensure
that the use of digital surveillance is
consistent with individual privacy civil
liberties and Democratic Values it will
also require the development of new
technologies and policies to protect
personal data from theft and misuse
number nine deep fakes in the metaverse
as the world becomes increasingly
digital the concept of the metaverse of
virtual reality space where people can
interact with each other and with
digital objects is becoming more
prominent honestly the metaverse holds
promise for entertainment social
connection and even Commerce but have
you heard of deep fakes deep fakes are
digital manipulations of audio video or
images that are so convincing that they
appear to be authentic I am not Morgan
Freeman and what you see is not real
well
at least in contemporary terms it is not
what if I were to tell you that I am not
even a human being
would you believe me while deep fakes
can be used for harmless fun such as
creating humorous videos they also can
be used for malicious purposes such as
spreading false information or defaming
individuals in the context of the
metaverse deep fakes could be
particularly problematic in a virtual
world where individuals can create and
customize their digital personas it may
become difficult to distinguish between
what is real and what is fake for
example someone could create a deep fake
of a public figure or celebrity and use
it to spread false information or defame
the individual's character an individual
could also create a deep fake of a
friend or family member and use it to
manipulate others or perpetrate fraud
this could lead to significant financial
or emotional harm for the victim and
those around them another significant
concern is the potential for deep fakes
to aggravate existing social and
political divides for example deep fakes
could be used to spread false
information or propaganda leading to
further polarization and confusion this
could have signed significant
implications for Democratic institutions
and the ability of individuals to make
informed decisions isn't it also
frightening that our education sector
can be affected if historical facts and
figures can be manipulated and even
recreated entirely if this would be
curbed there has to be a development of
new technologies and policies to detect
and mitigate the impact of deep fakes
this may include the use of advanced
algorithms and machine learning
techniques to detect deep fakes as well
as the development of policies to hold
individuals and organizations
accountable for the creation and
dissemination of false information
number 10. Nanobots Nanobots are tiny
machines that measure only a few
nanometers in size these microscopic
robots have the potential to
revolutionize the way we live work and
interact with our environment however
there are many concerns associated with
the development and use of Nanobots
including their impact on the
environment their potential use in
military applications and their impact
on privacy and individual autonomy one
area where Nanobots hold great promise
is medicine Nanobots could be used to
diagnose and treat diseases in a
targeted and precise way for example
they could be programmed to seek out
cancer cells and Destroy them without
damaging surrounding healthy tissues
this could lead to more effective and
less invasive treatments for a range of
diseases but what happens if say a
nanobot enters the brain it could
control an individual's thoughts or
actions and this could have significant
negative implications for individual
autonomy and privacy in addition to
Medical applications Nanobots have the
potential to be used in manufacturing
and other industrial processes for
example they could be used to assemble
complex structures at the molecular
level leading to the creation of new
materials with unique properties this
could lead to breakthroughs in areas
such as Electronics energy and Material
Science however the development and use
of Nanobots in manufacturing pose
environmental concerns for example if
Nanobots are released into the
environment they could disrupt eco
systems or even cause harm to humans and
animals it is therefore essential to
develop appropriate regulations and
safeguards to ensure the safe and
responsible use of Nanobots in
manufacturing and other industrial
processes Nanobots can also be useful in
the development of new military
Technologies Nanobots could be
programmed to seek out and Destroy enemy
targets potentially leading to new forms
of warfare and further eroding the
boundaries between civilian and Military
targets but there is also the risk of
unintentional harm to civilians and
non-combatants if clear guidelines and
regulations to govern the use of
Nanobots in military applications are
not put in place the human race should
be grateful for these emerging Tech
Innovations but if there is even the
slightest chance that they could
jeopardize our existence then it is
expedient that we hold the Applause and
focus on averting doomsday thank you for
watching if you found it engaging and
informative do give it a like and check
out any of these two videos to view
other interesting content